there was a retro challenge back in 2014
where Bobby sir is a challenge to do
something vetro computery so I decided
to convert the breadboard is an 80 on to
PCBs and labeled it all up Astley 2014
because that was what it was about a
Chinese special yes yes yep okay well
one if you've seen the previous video
it's pretty much the same kind of thing
you've still got the same said IT
processor 32 cave am a cave bomb
Microsoft basic on it you communicate
with it primarily over serial and yeah
you can run any any basic programs
effectively it sounds like you've got a
lot of fun in building this thing but
you go out and say just buy a Raspberry
Pi or some kind of arduino sector
where's the fun in that
where's the funny the this this is much
more much more back to the votes this is
if you if he was going to build a
computer back in late seventies early
eighties you would have bought the
components you would have soldered the
circuit boards together you would have
built it up from scratch from there so
it's it's more are you not back to the
past than necessarily the future like
the the pie or the Arduino so just
points of some of the bits you might
have to solver for the uninitiated yeah
actually what those disconnected modules
each of the chip sockets has to be
soldered on to the PCB all of the header
pins ones which got discrete components
like resistors and the crystals need to
be soldered on and the headers on to the
backplane and other trivial stuff there
was a lot to be soldered on on the back
there this is one above it yeah it's not
bad though your record for building one
of these at the moment is an hour and a
half that's that's from from unpacking
the kit getting out your soul you know
an hour and a half later yeah up and
running thank you stream what it used to
be like trying to do a new program prior
to github if he was lucky you had a
computer where there was a magazine for
it so every month you go down to the
news a just get your magazine and read
through all the comments and all the
listings in there so you could actually
type in the programs from scratch and
the magazine finding there if he was a
bit more niche there was a lot of male
groups which was literally post off the
information so yeah you'd receive a
package in the post unpack it all and
yeah you can type in your program from
there or you might even get floppy discs
in the post a lot of programs can be can
be adapted to run on this because if
once Microsoft basic there's a lot of
basic programs out there and yeah it's
very safe order to get those converted
across there's there's a growing
community now with the RC 2014 they're
also adding in their own bits of
software like like the fact all programs
from Newell's there so yeah which is all
being shared on get help ironically so
that's best that's the way it's done
these days
that's why yes yes if you still want to
do the typing code to by character you
can do the icky things which I decided
to do with this was was modulized
everything into its own individual basic
component and it all runs on a passive
backplane the backplane does nothing
other than join the parts together
essentially yes yes if you start from
the left hand side we've got the clock
module so that animates the clock signal
that runs the timing of everything there
next let we've got CPU that's at 80 cpu
running at 7
six megahertz on this one because that's
that's what the clocks running at next
to that we've got the the bomb which has
got Microsoft basic burnt on to it after
the bomb we've got 32 K of them it is
possible to double up on those if you
want 64 K for him quite what you do with
that amount of space no idea 64 cases
because he large what what sort you know
keep on that perspective how many how
much space is a program take up today's
to do say what's going on behind you oh
the the program for that is probably 1 K
maybe 1 and 1/2 K yeah it is very very
small and then only the white hand side
is the communication that's the serial
adapter there's this one here I've got
it connected to an FTDI lead so that
that is a usb-to-serial lead because it
speaks serial is there's so many things
out there which also speak cereal like
arduino is likewise beep eyes it's it's
the universal language so anything with
a serial pork and connecting and control
it it is very very easy to get into as
long as you know which end of a sold in
iron to hold you can build one of these
yeah that they are they are quite
straightforward it's all nice and easy
to solder stuff so there's there's no
complicated tricky surface melting zone
RS all simple through-hole so yeah
building the app is actually quite quite
straightforward as long as you can plug
it into the serial port you could to go
there's a whole bunch of terminal
emulation programs out there yeah things
like putty or whatever term which which
you're gonna use to talk through your
computer serial port ok then you just
connect to it and then you can start
programming exactly yes yeah as soon as
you turn the power on it's it's ready to
go you know 10 print computer file is
called 20 co2 10 we'd like to thank
audible.com for sponsoring this episode
a computer file and audible are offering
our viewers that's you guys free
audiobook and a 30 day free trial if you
go to audible.com slash computer file
this link here you'll have to use a
desktop device to go up and sign up and
then after that use a mobile device to
view what they've got to offer and
obviously listen to the books today I'd
like to recommend
creativity Inc by Ed Catmull ed couples
one of the cofounders of Pixar and he
talks all about how Pixar go about
making movies and how he was kind of
deflated after they had their first
success and that's all about him kind of
reaching his goal so he talks a little
bit about one or two of the important
ingredients that Pixar have and of
course remember they were the ones who
came out with the first feature film to
be fully animated on a computer so
there's a computer file angle there
thanks once again to audible for
sponsoring this episode of competes Val
quite a tactile thing to be doing it's
very very satisfied what would you like
a go